e niente abbiamo iniziato a giocare mi
ricordo che era questo gioco proprio
sembra proprio gioco Basic per bambini
con mi ricordo il mini gioco dove dovevi
riempire le forme colorate semplicemente
con lo strumento secchiello quelle cose
lì no che mi ricordo la prima volta che
ehm arrivavamo a quel livello lì mia
sorella non disse niente Io ero
terrorizzato io mi ricordo che quando
passavamo in quella zona lì perché ci
passavano più volte ero così ok
fermiamoci un attimo e spieghiamo cosa
sta succedendo il ragazzo che sta
parlando si chiama Matteo e mi ha
recentemente contattato per raccontarmi
una storia una storia che credeva mi
avrebbe interessato e aveva molta
ragione ma facciamo un passo indietro e
prendiamo questo discorso molto più alla
larga perché mi piace l'horror
[Musica]
e una cosa che da 34 anni che mi chiedo
ed ha più di una risposta la paura ha un
effetto positivo su di noi sia a livello
fisico perché tra il rilascio di
adrenalina e cortisolo ci sono questi
picchi di dopamina endorfine che ci
fanno stare così bene Ci aumenta il
battito cardiaco si dilatano le pupille
Insomma il riassunto è che la paura ci
fa sentire vivi ed è solo per questo
quindi che alcuni di noi che amano
questo genere decidono volontariamente
di farsi terrorizzare dai propri hobby E
a differenza di altre persone riusciamo
a goderne perché sai di essere al sicuro
guardando un film horror o giocando ad
un videogioco horror Perché sai che ti
spaventerai ma il tuo cervello capisce
anche che in realtà sei semplicemente
seduto sul divano seduto alla scrivania
al sicuro il mio non funziona così lo so
che non tutti funzionano così purtroppo
un articolo chiedeva sai perché la gente
quando esce dalle giostre pericolose o
dal cinema dopo aver visto un film
horror e contenta e ride per il Rush
chimico che ha il suo corpo per le
endorfine la dopamina E perché poi torna
a casa e sa che non c'è nessun mostro
sotto al letto forse e queste sensazioni
questi grandi spaventi sono i momenti
della nostra vita che ci ricordiamo di
più soprattutto quelli di quando eravamo
piccoli Mamma mia ormai ho perso il
conto di quelle scene in cose non horror
che mi hanno terrorizzato e Alcune sono
molto semplici Oserei dire banali nella
memoria collettiva di tutti come gli
elefantini Rosa In Dumbo o quello
stramaledettissimo tunnel della Fabbrica
di cioccolato
[Musica]
Gesù mio ed è qui che entri in gioco
Matteo e la sua mail dove mi racconta di
questa avventura grafica per bambini per
insegnamento dei bambini del 1998 per PC
chiamata foresta in maniera del tutto
Random dall'essere allegro e spensierato
con animali parlanti in stile Disney
diventa macabro e inquietante a questo
punto della mail stavo già saliando
avevo già l'acquolina in bocca pure i
colori svanivano l'unico colore visibile
era il rosso che invadeva lo schermo So
che può sembrare una Creepypasta ma è
tutto vero perfetto mollo tutto prendo
l'una prendo il van camperizzato e volo
da Matteo fargli un paio di domande
siamo ad Albissola Marina o Albissola
[Musica]
Vi ricordo che
quando iniziava il livello arriva a
questo drago che ti annunciava tipo
l'apocalisse alla fine del mondo prima
di contattarti parlando con mia sorella
e ho pensato a come si chiamava quel
gioco appena trovato su YouTube fuori ho
scritto gioco spaventoso per bambini lo
trovate subito come indicizzato bene
quindi questa cosa sta segna cioè te la
ricordi quasi a memoria questa cosa qui
perché poi del resto del gioco Non mi
ricordo quasi niente Cioè era tipo come
essere tornati dal Vietnam No perché tu
sì Poi ogni tanto magari Dieci anni dopo
rimani fermo bloccato e ti passano
davanti queste immagini della Grande
Quercia papà Quercia nella testa Quindi
tu non hai la copia non hai più la copia
No non ce l'ho più È un peccato perché
si sono sicuro che era localizzato in
italiano sicuramente al 100%. Avevi
ragione perché c'è localizzato in
italiano il gioco ma è rarissimo
rarissimo da trovare soprattutto fisico
e digitale non c'è da nessuna parte ma
prima di mettere le mani sulla copia di
Foresti e fammi fare una piccola ricerca
Fammi capire se effettivamente sia così
inquietante come dice la gente oppure se
semplicemente magari la memoria di
quando eri piccolo è un pochino distorta
voglio dire tutti siamo scappati dalla
sigla di x-files certo io scappavo anche
dalla musica dell'eurovisione quando
passava in RAI Ero terrorizzato da
questa da questa sigla
e ve lo giuro su Dio lo possiamo
chiedere a mia madre giuro su Dio e Ciao
mamma Guarda sto registrando un video
Volevo farti una domanda al volo
è vero che io avevo una paura
incredibile della sigla dell'eurovisione
in RAI te la ricordi
brava
[Musica]
Non era un fatto tuo di sensibilità che
sono degli idioti nella famiglia Eh
siamo un po' vero lasciando turbe mie ho
scoperto cercando che forestia e molto
rinomato per quella fantomatica scena
horror foresta un gioco educativo
perfettamente innocente degli anni 90
eccetto puntini puntini Ci sono anche un
paio di video di YouTube che lo
analizzano Certo con pochissime Visual
di qualche anno fa però vedi il gioco
per bambini non horror più spaventoso
Ok ok Abbiamo qualcosa tra le mani Io
comunque a questo punto della ricerca
non ho ancora né giocato né guardato
praticamente nulla di foresta perché
volevo essere spoiler free e leggendo in
continuazione scene horror in cose non
horror per bambini mi ritornano in mente
un sacco di scene specifiche un sacco di
immagini Io credo di non essermi mai più
ripreso dalla prima volta che ho visto
il ritorno di Oz per quel cazzo di
rotanti
e non è solo che fossero degli uomini su
delle ruote come uno di quegli
esperimenti or nazisti andati male ma è
come li presentano con quelle maschere
con quei primi piani Ma voi siete matti
e che poi crescendo in questo modo da
adulto queste immagini le percepisce
ovunque anche in cose che Sembrerebbero
molto semplici per esempio
horny Buddy questi innocentissimo
peluche di cane a cui tu puoi mettere
una penna per trasformarla nella sua
erezione
dai tre anni in su di galera Ma c'è un
problema non trovo la versione italiana
di foresta da nessuna parte e so che
esiste perché me l'ha scritto sia Matteo
nella mail sia l'ho letto in un forum
chiamato Crash Bandicoot zone dove
qualcuno chiedeva proprio di caricare la
copia
digitale di foreste in italiano perché
non si trova da nessuna parte e
purtroppo Matteo non trova più la sua di
coppia quindi mi riduca dover comprarne
una francese sia scatolato sia in
custodia DVD e già dalla scatola si può
intuire lo stile utilizzato per la
grafica di questa avventura simil Stop
Motion ma con animazioni anche 2D c'è
anche un bellissimo manuale colorato che
contiene la mappa di gioco quanto Adoro
ste cose C'è una formica col cappello da
pescatore con la valigia 24 ore che
credo vada al lavoro bellissimo però mi
ha dato così fastidio non avere la copia
italiana e tra le mani anche in formato
digitale che ho fatto la cosa che
avrebbe fatto chiunque al mio
presupposto ho fatto una storia di
Instagram chiedendo qualcuno ce l'ha e
con
74.000 account raggiunti mi hanno
risposto soltanto in due e solo uno
nella finestra temporale in cui stavo
lavorando al video 1 in 74.000 Andrea il
salvatore della patria che ha deciso di
estrarre la copia digitale dalla sua
personalissima copia fisica e me l'ha
fatta avere così sono riuscito a giocare
alla Coppa italiana di foreste ma
[__]
[Musica]
rispolvero il mio computer con Windows
98 installo foreste a cosa tra l'altro
che non facevo da tanti anni e lo faccio
partire
inizio una nuova partita Lui mi chiede
di mettere il nome e la mia età scrivo
Karim e questo nome è già stato usato
Sono in pericolo ditemelo se sono in
pericolo In che senso è già stato usato
quindi il gioco mi conosce benissimo
faccio finta di niente metto Io Toby e
inizia una nuova partita Ciao
Benvenuto visitatore così sei venuto a
dare un'occhiata alla nostra bella
foresta vengo immediatamente accolto da
Sam questo terrificante coniglio che ci
farà un po' da Virgilio che Ci
accompagnerà nella foresta e ci
insegnerà e l'utilizzo di tutte le icone
e di tutti i tasti conosco questa
foresta come le mie età
dice di avere qualcosa per me tira fuori
l'ampolla ne fa cadere una goccia per
terra c'è un'esplosione di luce e un
uccellino muore
esplorando un pochino la mappa incontro
uno dei personaggi chiave di tutta
l'avventura papà Quercia questo
accogliente e saggio o proprio
disfunzionale dispensa consigli
accompagnato da una non meno inquietante
betulla e io amico mio perché non voglio
giocare con lui ma non facciamo in tempo
a scambiare due convenevoli che arriva
questo fastidiosissimo scoiattolo che
inizia a rompere le balle
papà Querce Betulla che non volevano far
altro che farsi un sonno dicono senti
portatelo di là sto rincoglionito fa
vedi cosa vuole in seguito perché noi
vogliamo riposare così staremo un po' in
pace
Quindi tu lo insegui in mezzo alla
Foresta fino a casa sua e lui ti invita
a giocare a una sottospecie di gioco
dell'oca dove devi tirare il dado e in
base alla casella in cui finisci devi
rispondere delle domande devo dire anche
Abbastanza specifiche sugli animali a
volte molto semplici tipo Come respirano
i pesci a volte molto più complesse per
esempio ti fa sentire il verso di un
animale tu devi indovinarlo e io l'ho
indovinato per culo esatto
tra l'altro questo scoiattolo non è
soltanto un [__] Ma è anche un
pezzettino di stronzo perché ogni volta
che sbaglio una domanda e lui ad andare
avanti di tre Caselle così perché se l'è
inventate lui le regole la
risposta vado avanti io di tre Caselle e
immediatamente si fa notte papà Quercia
nota che Sem e sopra una torre di
avvistamento e ti chiede di raggiungerlo
io ci ho messo un bel po' per
raggiungerlo perché la foresta è un po'
complicata da navigare fotografia per
fotografia un po' come se fosse Google
Street View ed essendo notte fatta con
un filtro blu e basta Non si capisce
esattamente cosa i tuoi occhi stiano
guardando a volte e tutto questo senza
musica ma solo con i rumori di fondo e
sembra davvero di essere dentro una
foresta perduti ma tutto questo si
annulla quando camminando trovo una
musicassetta
Che c'è Non vi è mai capitato di
camminare in mezzo alla Foresta e
trovare un cd musicale con una colonna
sonora completamente fuori luogo capita
eh
[Musica]
e dopo quattro ore e un quarto
Finalmente riesco a raggiungere Sam su
questa torre che voleva semplicemente
farmi vedere una nuova costellazione il
dragone
è bellissima
bene ora sono stanco Vado a dormire e
niente Solo questo ci voleva dire voleva
solo farci perdere un po' di tempo tanto
che poi mi dice pure Vabbè sono stanco
vado via e anche noi ci corichiamo in
cima alla torre ed è lì che inizia
l'incubo
[Musica]
E questa sezione che sta per iniziare di
gioco non è una cosa che arriva
gradualmente ma di punto in bianco vai a
dormire e ti svegli all'inferno
[Musica]
tutta la mappa è ricoperta di rosso
fuoco e c'è questa musica
inquietantissima in sottofondo ad un
certo punto in lontananza vedi arrivare
un drago con gli occhi illuminati che ti
sorpassa fai un passo avanti e trovi uno
degli animali della foresta rinchiuso in
una gabbia vai da lui presto
[Musica]
e questo è solo l'inizio ma voi
immaginatevi la scena di un bambino di
4-5 anni seduto in camera da solo che
sta giocando un gioco
educativo e vede una cosa del genere dal
nulla e se non mi ricordo male Matteo mi
ha proprio detto che gliel'hanno dato a
scuola e mi ricordo che il gioco Infatti
me l'aveva dato l'asilo in cui ero stato
e avevano dato non mi ricordo se a
ciascuno di noi o solo ad alcuni Questo
gioco che era appunto foresta pensa i
compiti a casa tema foresta svolgimento
Dio mio Dio
Quindi tu parti alla ricerca di questo
drago per salvare la situazione durante
l'esplorazione della mappa non so come
dirvelo tu trovi in mezzo alla strada i
cadaveri degli altri animali della
foresta e se interagisci con loro
[Musica]
vedi la loro anima lasciare il proprio
corpo In un gioco educativo per come fa
a essere legale questa cosa
quindi cerco di immedesimarmi in un
bambino sei nel panico più totale Non
sai dove andare Non sai cosa fai Hai una
paura [__] quindi cerchi di trovare
la cosa più confortevole e familiare che
ci sia in Foresta papà quercia
di solito nel gioco quando tu sei
bloccato vai da loro e sono quelli che
ti dicono come proseguire Esatto
ma è morto
cazzo è come se il virus di The Last of
Us avesse colpito gli alberi parlanti di
Gardaland la distruzione è totale e
tutto in rovina e sono tutti morti e
anche vero che se sbagli strada nella
mappa all'improvviso appare un mago
rapper che con il suo bit leggermente
fuori luogo potrebbe rovinare
l'atmosfera
cavaliere Stai perdendo la strada la
torre di moro non è da quella parte ma
non ci pensiamo non ci pensiamo in una
delle strade secondarie c'è anche un
jamscar
mi trovo davanti ad un portone vedo un
signor oscuro uscire e lasciare la
chiave nascosta rubo la chiave apro il
portone e mi ritrovo davanti ad uno
scheletro parlante
metterai al loro giusto posto Noi
Certamente potremo stare meglio salgo
sopra la torre e vedo una serie di
cristalli ed è lì che mi ricordo
Un'altra cosa che mi ha detto Matteo uno
nei commenti ha scritto ho provato a
mettere i cristalli nella posizione
sbagliata e me ne sono pentito e tutti i
commenti li han scritto Ma cosa è
successo e questo non ha risposto
piccolo
tutto ciò mi rende ancora più forte Hai
perso questa occasione Addio
Ragazzi ma che deve succedere ancora c'è
manca solo uno sviluppatore che con uno
sgabello me lo spacca in testa e abbiamo
l'orrore definitivo Ricomincio da capo
questa sessione infernale trovo il drago
che anche lui pur essendo un personaggio
buono ha una presentazione molto
inquietante
mi dice dove andare trovo la posizione
esatta dei cristalli torno alla torre li
posiziono e finisce l'incubo e si scopre
essere letteralmente un incubo perché
stavamo sognando ma non ti preoccupare i
draghi Non esistono o Così pensavo ho
liberato foreste dalla maledizione di
moreurne il Terribile stregone O forse è
stato solo un brutto sogno non lo era o
ancora una foto del drago È assurdo e è
bellissimo ti lascia anche il dubbio di
cosa sia realmente successo Quindi
potrebbe non essere un sogno quindi
potrebbe essere tipo una visione del
futuro mi ricorda quella scena di
Smallville dove una signora anziana vede
il futuro di Lex Luthor ed è lui in un
campo di girasoli che piano piano
iniziano a morire quando lui li tocca ed
inizia a piovere sangue la signora
anziana dopo che ha la visione muore e
questa sezione esattamente così ma
10.000 volte peggio è stata una delle
esperienze
inaspettate della mia vita perché è nata
dal nulla ed ha portato alla conoscenza
di un qualcosa che non avevo mai sentito
prima d'ora che ho provato con le mie
mani e ho potuto confermare tutto quello
che ho letto su Internet per mesi Questa
è una perla che va a salvaguardata Ed è
esattamente quello che ho voluto fare ho
chiesto il permesso ad Andrea di poter
caricare la versione digitale di foresta
in italiano su internet arcaives in modo
da salvaguardarla averla a disposizione
di tutti nei secoli dei secoli
fondamentalmente e sono molto felice di
questo
discepoli Benvenuti
[Musica]
Tu lo sai cosa devi fare per proteggere
la tua connessione devi usare nordvpn
Dove vai ti ritrovi perduto in una
foresta come tante e all'improvviso
trovi una misteriosa connessione libera
ti fidi non ti fidi con nordvpn non ha
in questo dubbio Mamma mia Metti caso
che la foresta si trovi in Cambogia e
hai bisogno di guardare contenuti del
tuo paese che cosa fai uso norvpn col
codice sconto Yotobi bravo e attivando
la Tret Protection potrei avere
protezione contro malware e siti dannosi
Scaricatelo trovi con il codice sconto
Yotobi in descrizione
[Musica]